previously on TV Sara's mother did you
see that the hell is up with this house
there are windows up in the bedrooms
that look over the front but then these
windows on the right side are roughly
four to six feet below those they're a
magical pseudo third storey here that's
like platform nine and three-quarters
Meg's refusal to at the very least
Center herself in her casual tv-watching
posture is driving my feng shui OCD up
the wall enough to throw off my sandwich
did you know that televisions used to
have tiny electronic nipples that had to
be twisted in order to find the right
frequency that's because they didn't why
does this TV have nipples mom dad I
found cigarettes in Greg's jacket it's
only fitting that the show starts off
with a direct pop culture parody since
that's representative of approximately
95% of the MacFarlane repertoire
I mean imagine believing you could
simply make pop-culture references and
stupid little running jokes and somehow
make a living off of it as if you think
the people who boast about good
old-fashioned values would replace these
bean people's stock images with actual
photos of their family lazy everyone has
ears parallel to or above their eyes
meaning Louis has large cheek piercings
and not ear piercings this is fine but
why not show her badassery and flaunt
those cheek jewels this theme song will
get stale over the duration of the 42
seasons this shows been on the air but I
do have to give it credit for being so
grammatically correct that it doesn't
even use a preposition to end a sentence
with a fan for some reason I thought
this freak genius baby saying F and cry
now that I've watched it with subtitles
I realize he sings laugh and cry my
point is that I thought this would be
the kind of show or a baby says F and
the damn theme song and that's probably
the greatest sin of them all man this
show Simpsons is so hard in the first
minute and change it makes you wonder if
Fox had a CW like checklist for their
animated sitcoms can I please get
collagen injections it's easy to forget
that meg wood from being voiced by a
meme girl to a bad mom you know most of
the world's problems stem from poor
self-image we made it to the first
Holocaust joke in less than two minutes
that's a record that may never be beats
like wilts 100 Sion 7
59 and Lisa Sparks is 919 all rolled
into one no toy Stewie no toys but a
screwdriver is okay I'm starting to
wonder about the ship that Lois is
running around here when you least
expect it you're up ins will come fun
fact
you're up ins will come is the working
title of my yet to reach completion
Shakespearean foreign parody he's going
to a stag party stag party even in the
late 90s that was passe only Catholics
have been depicted in ballet his first
position does this have a deeper meaning
or is it a lazy animation choice
those poor piriformis oh is that really
the blood of Christ is this really the
first time Peters ever been to church I
guess it is possible but it's much more
possible that this is just an
incongruous setup to a cheap punchline I
got it that's the guy from big Tom Hanks
that's it ah funny guy I know I'm
supposed to believe that all these
people are irritated because of how
emotional Philadelphia is but my guess
is it has more to do with now they're
forced to think about big which is the
darkest goddamn movie to ever be a hits
an hour and 44 minutes of statutory rape
big I have AIDS
we got age jokes y'all why did they have
to copy so many previously animated
shows with the four fingered characters
here is it that hard to do five I'm
gonna look this up searching searching
holy the answer is much more complicated
than I care to consider so the sin
stands dammit that I bring up aw now I
have so many questions
should I a text have you ever watched
porn with seven other men to my buddy to
gain perspective be Google casual group
porn screening 101 or C except that in
this cartoon world this is a totally
acceptable weeknight with drinking
buddies what is this man my kid must
have taped over this for history class I
know this is in the service of a joke
but is Peter seriously saying mayor
Chris both of whom are adolescents with
raging hormones took a sublime out of
the cover taped over the little holes on
top and recorded a history program in
the middle of the phone taped
synchronized slurping it's your job to
watch for any toys that could be
hazardous to children is a seriously
peter's job at the beginning of the show
how does he afford that big-ass house
and provide for three kids you've been
using cartoon logic please George Jetson
had an actual important job to be able
to afford that space apartment and now
back to Action News five our top story
tonight if we're returning to Action
News five why are they just starting the
top story well there's the traffic
problem right there nobody's driving
wait is this that jesus take the wheel
thing i've been hearing about all that
you do standing it it's tuna fish that's
either green tuna fish or there's
lettuce on his tuna fish sandwich by the
way that's some simple tuna they might
want to just tell Louis the truth what
but I can't provide for my family
yeah these goddamn food stamps don't buy
diapers and it's no movie there's no
mekhi phifer this is my life open
cabinet doors in a dark room are an
instance in for me anyone who can't
close a cabinet door can eat a knob hey
where's the other guy it's inception
literally the newspaper changes titles
from daily informant to daily Times and
I'm just saying the show has severely
under played this futuristic news
technology oh I didn't have guests for
the first time and tell I was 30 wait
how the fold is Peter if this is his
hippie ass at 30 years old also 30 years
of gas buildup and this is all we get
that beanbag should have been shot out
of the window and a poof of cracked
leather and styrofoam snow we're
officially on welfare come on kids help
me scatter carpets on a front lawn
that's welfarist mr. president why do
you think the American public has
continued to support you throughout
these impeachment proceedings Oh
probably cuz you're so fat me and my
Oval Office when did you guys get a pool
oh it's a moat
this is the fourth or fifth I've
honestly lost count a different
extravagant expenditure joke they've
done in a rough show doesn't have a
story as much as it has a series of
mind-numbingly inane thought experiments
that are masquerading as some sort of
shock humor the fact that the brain
responsible for this crap somehow went
on to make the Orval should be an
inspiration to us all I feel like I
don't even know you anymore cliche yes
in the Superbowl announcer's booth they
have a single hanging framed picture of
a football helmet just in case anyone
forgets the sport they're commentating
on the Fox one gun at Fox life is like a
box of chocolates
you never know what you're going to get
I think the dump quote you were looking
for was stupid is a stew
does your welcome these clear buttons
are a reminder that the button
consistency in this show is unhinged and
I've had enough this show goes from
clear buttons to no buttons to solid
buttons then she has lighter buttons and
one at the top but now they are clear
buttons and none at the top then solid
buttons then buttons back up he has
buttons now he has no buttons for the
clear buttons for dark buttons Oh
buttons Forks if there's one priority in
good comedy its button consistency and
we will not stand for your shoddy
craftsmanship any longer money money
money who do you trust what we gonna do
tomorrow night the same thing we do
every night pinky try to take over the
world I have it everyone has a
[Music]
[ __ ] man I thought you people were
supposed to be jolly what do you mean
you people